I think what inspired me as a creative
in the world of Harry Potter was the
realism within the world there was a
sort of grit and dirt and history and
everything and it felt like it really
existed and it was a real world at some
point in time
[Applause]
[Music]
I love Terry Potter I read all the books
watched all the movies but there was
nobody I could really relate to
there was one Asian girl and she was
Chinese but I'm Filipino I would have
loved to see more people of color in all
the film
[Music]
you
[Music]
my favorite thing about Harry Potter is
JK Rowling she was a full-time working
single mother when she wrote this book
she had no time for herself she had to
raise children figure out how to live
and yet she still managed to create one
of the most popular and beloved
best-selling books series of all time
that also became a best-selling movie
franchise
[Music]
[Music]
growing up I was a fan a huge fan of
Harry Potter but never really saw myself
represented in the world being as a
Hispanic and Asian American
[Music]
you
[Music]
I grew up believing in magic because of
my Egyptian background that's how I was
connected to Harry Potter world
I just wish our my culture was presented
a little bit more reading the books you
couldn't help but envision yourself as
these characters so not seeing that on
the screen was a bit of a disappointment
but it is nice to pretend to be what you
wish you would have seen I could never
be part of the Harry Potter world
because I'm a muggle so I wish I could
see more ordinary people doing
extraordinary things I wish I had seen
more warriors professors and just
characters of all kinds and Harry Potter
that were women of color
[Music]
[Music]